americans love beer will appear so much
we drink nearly fifty six billion points
of it a year but that love comes with a
price each point we hoist requires as
much as five pints of water to produce
in a state like California where water
is in short supply that man could become
a massive problem for brewers unless you
disc the craft brewing industry in
California is very big and growing it is
been growing at over ten percent a year
for over a decade and there are dozens
of craft breweries opening up every
month in California for every pint of
beer that you drink four or five pints
of water used in its production there's
obviously the water that's in the pint
of beer you drink itself but water is
used in its production and cleaning the
equipment in the entire process of
growing it so beer is an extraordinarily
water intensive product so we're the
only brewery that is actually making a
beer out of recycled water that may not
sound like much but every day
Californians flush 1.3 billion gallons
of water down the drain that wastewater
usually runs through sewers and
ultimately out into the Pacific Ocean
but it doesn't have to it can be
reclaimed cleaned and used again for
Half Moon Bay every ounce of recycled
water it uses is one ounce of fresh
water it doesn't need to pull from
California's already depleted supply we
think it is a chance to help redefine
the value of water in beer we think it's
a chance to help people understand the
importance of water and we think it's a
chance to change the entire mindset
about recycled water is not something
you should be scared of it should be
something that you think is interesting
and different since recycled water isn't
readily available in California half
moon bay had to go to an unusual source
to test their idea so you are using
in this particular experiment recycled
water for your beer we're even getting
the recycled water from well we've
sourced it from NASA and so what were
they using the recycled water for well
they use it for obviously the Space
Shuttle the astronauts far as I know
watering plants around the facility all
that kind of stuff once you've gotten
the water to a profile that you would
like do you work with it the same way
you would work with tap water yeah it is
very much like the standard water that
we use here in the brewery so generally
the PHS are the same once it's been
filtered and everything we do add a
little bit of brewing salts back to it
to enhance its flavor a little bit would
you be adding brewing salts to tap water
when you're working with that absolutely
okay so it's the same it's the same
thing for Lenny's bed on recycled water
to work the beer made from it can't be
almost as good it has to be as good or
better than the original so I sat down
with Dan Littlefield master brewer and
nearby competitor to Half Moon Bay to
conduct a proper taste test Cheers
now how would you describe this as a
master brewer well i mean first off this
is a really well-balanced multi and very
hoppy beer I sure I'm getting a lot of
flavor let's try this one
right off the get-go I'm not getting a
huge difference here I'm actually I'm
pretty impressed by by just just how
good both of them are mr. Nate will you
reveal the truth that we need to know
here IPA that was brewed with recycled
grey water yes someone's on the outside
hey that's when I had my hand on you see
that that's the one I drink more you do
it yeah no it's delicious currently Half
Moon Bay can't sell the beer it's making
from recycled wastewater but Lenny
thinks it's just a matter of time before
it can so I think it's going to be at
least a year or two before regulation
and all this is legal to do for consumer
consumption but I would imagine in 5-10
years from now the u.s. water system
especially in places like California
where we have scarcity and drought
pretty frequently it will be part of the
regular system
what happen one day is doing may seem
radical when dealing with something as
traditional as beer but conditions in
California are calling for bold new
ideas and since beer made from recycled
water can taste just as good or better
than traditional sources it seems like a
no-brainer after all if you could enjoy
a crisp refreshing pint of beer while
also contributing to water conservation
and helping preserve the environment I
wouldn't you